I am fluent in Fraggle.
I took, like, 4 years of Fraggle in high school.
I'm very new to the Fraggle language, so, I'll go with it.
You ready for a quiz then?
Where do I sign up?
Go ahead. Sure.
I don't have a lot of Fraggles to practice with
so who knows how much I remember.
Did you say games?
I'm in!
What is a 'merggle'?
I'm going to assume it's something to do with music?
That is the
slide where the...you know...
Well everyone knows that a 'merggle' is
a special kind of satchel
and you carry around your
Doozer sticks in a merggle
so you can snack on them later.
Right? I don't know.
I don't know what a 'merggle' is.
Oh, they're a race of aquatic Fraggles
who live among the roots
and limbs of the Great Tree.
Oh!
Yeah. There you go.
What are 'stinkleberries'?
Um...I have no idea.
It's pretty self explanatory.
Stinkleberries are considered a delicacy.
They're terrible for you. Rot your teeth.
They're tiny. They're like...
Some Fraggles make preserves out of them.
I don't get it.
Yeah, I don't. [all murmuring]
Stinkleberries are a berry fruit
that typically grow near the trash heap.
They smell awful,
and can be used to un-freeze a Fraggle.
There it is.
It's pretty much what I said.
No I don't think so.
Yeah. I had that completely wrong.
Who's ready?
What is a 'baloobius'?
'Baloobius'?
Uh...
Is it something to do with light?
It's glowing!
Is it like the end of a tail?
Come on, tail. Do something!
Yes!
The Baloobius is the fringe
on the end of a Fraggle's tail.
It tends to flare out when the Fraggle is scared
and can even glow when a Fraggle feels truly
at peace with oneself.
See! Light!
Oh, yeah. Ah, that's right.
Whoa it's like a party on your tail!
Are you kidding me! Of course!
Down in Fraggle Rock!